[Music]
this is it I'll take care of I'll put
your dear daughter's hands right after
this I promise this surgery is honestly
probably the scariest thing I've ever
done in my life I mean I could die from
it I'm not one to let go of control very
easily and I have no control over this
situation once I put me to sleep I mean
I really hope I made the right decision
there isn't they're trying to pay now
there you go
gas on please all right let's begin
nice she got a bit of a uterine stomach
gotta be careful with that yeah all
right let's start by taking the short
gastric vessels that are connecting the
fat to the stomach here so that we can
work with the stomach without it
bleeding all right that should give me a
lot of freedom okay I'm ready for the
gastric tube here it comes slow now then
guide you in the sizing tube is placed
all the way from the beginning of the
stomach to the end of the stomach and we
cut everything outside of the sizing -
all right we are ready to take the
stomach out now you're loaded all right
let's do it
stapler ready fire
we're using a special surgical stapler
that lays three rows of titanium staples
that seals as it cuts so that there is
no bleeding
showing the staple line please
[Music]
dr. Harvard hold on one second please
you're venting a little too much I need
some more light on this Erica she's
stable going to bleed
[Music]
you